[Música]
para nosotros es momento de ir en
directo a Brasil y es que ahí hay
expectativa antes de una nueva audiencia
prevista para mañana martes en la que el
expresidente Jair bolsonaro deberá
enfrentar nuevamente al tribunal
superior electoral en el marco de un
juicio clave que podría inhabilitarlo
para ejercer cargos públicos durante
ocho años el ultraderechista está
acusado de abuso de poder y
desinformación concretamente por
utilizar los canales de comunicación del
gobierno para promover su campaña y
difundir dudas infundadas sobre el
sistema de votación electrónica en los
comicios de octubre de 2022 cuando
recordemos ganó Luis Ignacio ludra da
Silva la presidencia conectamos ahora
con nuestra corresponsal Valeria Valeria
buenas noches para usted esta es la
segunda audiencia de bolsonaro ante el
tribunal Qué ocurrió en la primera
recordemos lo Y qué se espera para la
segunda
el Tribunal Superior electoral alcanzó
la semana pasada a instruir el caso y a
enumerar los supuestos delitos cometidos
por Jairo bolsonaro eso es abuso de
poder diseminación de noticias falsas
sobre el sistema electoral con fines
también electorales y también ataques
contra el sistema democrático la defensa
de bolso alegó que la reunión con los
diplomáticos extranjeros se realizó
antes del período electoral y que por
eso no sería delito mañana a las 7 de la
noche Se reanuda el segundo día de
juicio siete jueces están llamados a
leer su decisión se espera un resultado
de 6 a 1 que inhabilitaría bolsonaron la
cuestión es cuando se va a realizar esta
decisión el presidente del tribunal
Alexander demorais considerado un
enemigo Jurado de bolsonaro ha pedido
brevedad para que para el día 29 de este
mes tengamos una resolución sin embargo
hay una incógnita el juez fiel a
bolsonaron un smartges nombrado para él
para el supremo podría pedir una vista
preliminar y en este caso se suspendería
el juicio para un período de hasta 60
días Valeria Valeria y en qué otras
causas judiciales que podrían
comprometer Su futuro político se
encuentra también inmerso el mandatario
son muchos los problemas que bolsonaro
tiene en los tribunales concretamente en
la Corte Suprema responde por seis
investigaciones son varias una es la
discriminación de noticias falsas y la
creación de verdaderas milicias
digitales además el tema más importante
es si él fue el autor intelectual
del intento de golpe que vimos a
principio de este año el 8 de enero fue
perpetrado por sus seguidores que
causaron destrozos en la plaza de los
tres poderes de Brasilia pero cada vez a
más evidencias que él podría estar
detrás de este intento y es precisamente
lo que intentan descubrir los jueces
además bolsonaro también tiene que
responder por el caso de las joyas que
fueron dadas como regalo por las
autoridades de Arabia saudí son joyas
valoradas en hasta tres millones y medio
de dólares lo normal que haría cualquier
presidente es entregarlas al archivo
presidencial si un presidente quiere
quedarse con estas joyas debería
declararlas y pagar los impuestos pero
hubo varios intentos por parte de la
familia bolsonaro de quitar esas joyas
de el bloqueo en la aduana brasileña
hubo hasta ocho intentos y precisamente
por esta razón bolsonaro tendrá que
responder en los tribunales son varios
los juicios incluso una historia
relacionada con una ex empleada de
bolsonaro que sería una empleada
fantasma esto en la justicia regular Y
por esa razón se espera que bolsonaro
tenga que responder en los próximos
meses y que tenga que aclarar varios
puntos de su conducta durante su mandato